e aí pessoas que têm tudo bom e pessoas
que curtirem o canal do povo vocês falam
eu estou aqui para falar mais um
desabafo aqui pra vocês é o seguinte
todo lugar que você vai na internet que
você vai na rua o pessoal tá queimando a
copa do mundo o brasil aos estádios vão
ficar pronto este é o país que vai
sediar a copa a que a educação no brasil
é muito ruim e se o país vai sediar a
copa
ai que hoje eu tenho um pé defendeu
demais esse é o país que vai sediar a
copa
gente porque esse pessimismo tudo
consiste em pôr pra que esse péssimo
tudo pra que isso vem nomes e é falso
moralismo é quando a pessoa fala mais em
determinada coisa e se essa coisa é
certa ela simplesmente muda de opinião
porque essa pessoa está falando que não
devia ter copa no brasil por causa disso
tem bico em mas caso dê certo essa
pessoa falar lá eu aquela mas a copa do
mundo não pode ser um brasil para as
crianças da aacc estou morrendo caro
assim assim da áfrica cara você que está
me assistindo agora sim algum assunto
você mente esquecer da áfrica no meio
você já é 50% imbecil porque
praticamente 100% das pessoas de fadas
crescer dar numa onda ume hoje pra ela a
madonna estava jantando 30 20 minutos ea
angelina jolie e brad pitt estão lá todo
dia rolar carrega três pra casa e tu faz
o tempo tá metendo as crianças em data
no meio porque o brasileiro só torce pra
dar errado essa copa do mundo aqui no
brasil mas se a copa fosse na tailândia
avançou muito fala ai ai tem copa na
tailândia
e aqui no brasil tem muita gente a
américa vai falar pra mim não foi
verdade para a copa do mundo foi na
áfrica todo mundo regionais
ai tem copa na áfrica ainda em copa na
áfrica porque aqui não tem o brasil tem
problema tem sim a pessoa vai lá no
facebook faz montagens com fotos
pega uma criança passando fome é mário e
tal busca desse tamanho
as perna fina e tal agora a legenda
tinha
será que a copa do mundo é mesmo nessa
manhã
unidade por agora é pra mim tu acha que
a pessoa que inventou isso tá preocupado
com a sempre em cima da foto ela quer
compartilhamento [ __ ] não quero que
você pense que estou fazendo esse vídeo
aqui para apoiar a copa não é só quero
que você pede atenção que a copa não é a
nossa maior prioridade mas também não é
a nossa pior desgraça não quero que você
pensa que eu também sou insensível um
livro com as criancinhas da áfrica não
tá eu só acho que ele não tem condição
de ajudar tem-se da frente cala a boca e
não fica enfiado no nome delas em toda
besteira que se acha na internet porque
não quer que a copa seja aqui cara
porque se porque o ser humano a cada dia
ele fica reclamando tanto das coisas
contam buraco na rua leva lá assegurado
na rua e segurar como deixou passar aí
vai lá as máquinas para tampar o buraco
da rotai a mulher chega à noite a ai ai
tem máquina que no meio da rua 8 do
bairro deixou passar
a hipotermia e e consertou lá por um
buraco e tal
a mãe passa lá e se desse buraco aqui é
kamal tampada
o cala a boca veiga pelo todo dia uma
pessoa reclama de uma coisa não entendo
a educação no brasil a educação no
brasil é uma bosta educação tanto brasil
a a desgraça olha pra mim olha pra mim
olha pra mim
o professor que recebe mal ele tem
direito de falar isso o aluno estudioso
que se esforçasse todas as aulas por dia
estuda duas horas três horas em casa ele
tem o direito de falar isso agora você e
eu que ia para a escola e de 5 a matava
3 a gente não tem o direito de falar da
educação no brasil eu estou sendo
sincero pra você e eu tô sendo sincero
pra vocês ea maioria de vocês está
assistindo também sabe eu sei tem
aquelas pessoas que estudam bem mas tem
a maioria de vocês que sabe o que eu tô
falando que vai pra escola pb abc não
volta mais que inventou o barril para
ficar a dormir em casa é isso é
realidade onde você abrir sua boca pra
ficar fazendo baderna e fale besteira
você olha para sua vida e veja se você
está certo é o cara vai lá no youtube a
essa paródia que ensina o meu deus do
céu 5 milhões de exibições como é que as
pessoas podem gostar de uma bosta dessa
forma que o brasil gosta gente esse é o
brasil que mostra os boston em cima da
sua boca
lá em cima no youtube não foi o brasil
que escolheu não é apenas uma parcela
dessas pessoas estão assistindo então
viu um vídeo no youtube não gostou
fechar a aba modcom facebook volte por
cut que é onde você devia tar que olha
eu fico triste eu fico triste quando o
gringo está fora e chegam brasileiro o
cara fica assim sabe que é isso aí é o
brasil ao falar ah isso aí é culpa do
governo sírio culpa do vento o governo é
o [ __ ] para eu estou aqui defendendo
o governo não mas quem faz o brasil são
os brasileiros se a gente não falar lá
fora a culpa é nossa culpa do político
do brasil é também vamos dizer que 50
por cento da culpa dele a outra a outra
de quem a outra
a outra é nossa vez que o brasil para o
brasil é um lugar onde a gente vive de
sexta em sexta-feira a equipe preocupa
no facebook a e se preocupa não é
simples
ai galera relaxa é se esta época olha
pra mim quanto tempo vai ficar vendo de
sexta feira
uma coisa posso fazer durante a semana e
para quê ficar vivendo de sexta feira e
fica à porta desta sexta-feira ai meu
deus amanhã é segunda linha é segunda a
segunda feira um dia igual a todos os do
dia duda a semana o que fará a segunda
feira ser boa não é você se você for um
imbecil a segunda feira vai ser horrível
mas se você compensou criar eu só fazer
alguma coisa sua vida de útil
segunda-feira é que na sexta então pode
ficar enchendo o saco quando for sexta
feira e vai viver
a gente tá vivendo um brasil em que se a
pessoa não tem namorada no bar nada mas
se a pessoa tem namorado meu deus do céu
chove de pessoas querendo que diabo é
isso vem é um instinto de fazer o mal
está vivendo um brasil e disse a
sexta-feira não chega logo nenhum se
mata a gente tá vivendo um brasil que
camaro amarelo ganhou como melhor música
do ano a gente vem no brasil se tem
buraco na noite é como se tanto bater na
tecla que está mal tampadas a itália vem
no brasil em que aqui tem tem policial
que é ladrão a tem tem tem tem político
que é ladrão gente toda a área que você
for na sua vida vai ter um filho da [ __ ]
lá dentro a advogada da [ __ ] engenheiro
da [ __ ] médico da [ __ ] da [ __ ] falar da
[ __ ] tudo tem que ter um filho e quem no
meio para de pensar que você
achar uma coisa que é totalmente certa
para de pensar e se viva sua vida é seja
feliz não é isso quero pedir pra você
que você pode reclamar mais as coisas e
e viva direito efe beleza então se você
está vendo no facebook por favor curta
essa postagem compartilha marcando
alguém se você está vendo esse vídeo no
twitter e dar rt que isso ajuda muito se
você está vendo isso no youtube clique
em adicionar aos favoritos e 30 que
gostei
se você tem alguma coisa que não gostou
desse vídeo se você gostou e quer
acrescentar alguma coisa comenta aqui
embaixo e eu vou ler todos os
comentários se você ainda não está
inscrito neste canal se é o primeiro
vídeo que você está vendo meu quer ver
mais vídeos clique aqui e inscrever-se
aqui em baixo para ver se a vida você
vai ver e assistir os outros vídeos aí
me segue no twitter me assina no
facebook se você quiser saber mais sobre
mim é claro que não deixa pra lá e falou